also taking on engine but i mean we
don't see magnus carson really
looking and look at this rook d2 another
engine says black is completely winning
because
g7 and g1 queen that's it
what just happened
well one could even argue that this is
not a positive
change compared to the over the board
that looked like g7 would not be taking
the look it would be
the same movie i like you you just take
but but black is black is still fighting
i mean luke h6 is coming
peter you know the fact the fact that
rook g7 was not played with
winning on the spot is just i mean i
don't even
i i don't know what to say i mean and i
feel that alexander
it's just a blind spot for him that it
just because he didn't even realize it
after he moved it
yeah maybe that's that's very good for
him if he doesn't realize then he can
continue play the game normally if
he realizes then how do you continue i
mean oh my god
i mean you could have won the game on
the spot a position which was
okay crazy but probably bad for you uh
however now again
black black should be fine but white is
in time we are capturing on a7 and we'll
have this
e5 counter play it it does feel that
finally
it might lead to some though but still
the position is such a crazy position
that
i'm i would not dare to say that this is
already a dead law